speaking of the supposed conversations
that took place between fired FBI
director James Comey and Donald Trump of
course the back story being that last
week James Comey was fired by Donald
Trump the letter from Donald Trump
explaining the firing references James
Comey supposedly telling Donald Trump
three times that he was an under
investigation this is a very bizarre
thing to include in the letter it's also
apparently untrue more on that later
very strange tweet from Donald Trump
about this entire thing on Friday where
he tweeted quote James Comey better hope
that there are no tapes of our
conversations before he starts leaking
to the press this could be understood in
two different ways number one is Donald
Trump here is basically threatening
James Comey for basically saying I
secretly recorded our meetings and
conversations and if James Comey is
going to come out and say anything that
might not be accurate about what was or
wasn't said in those meetings he had
better think twice because Donald Trump
has it has it on tape and that Comey had
better be careful the other
interpretation would be Trump is
implying that if James Comey secretly
recorded FBI investigations he'd better
be careful if he's going to try to leak
those recordings now I would find it
absolutely shocking
if James Comey was the one recording a
conversation in the White House the idea
that the FBI director would secretly
bring in recording devices to the White
House to record his meeting with the
president I have a very hard time
believing that more likely is that if
there are any recordings of that meeting
between James Comey and Donald Trump
that it was Trump who actually did the
recording because Trump according to
former do two employees of Trump's
former job which was running the Trump
Organization Donald Trump supposedly did
sometimes secretly record conversations
with employees what we do know is that
current and former
FBI officials dispute the
characterization from Donald Trump of
that meeting with James Comey from
earlier this year Trump in an interview
with NBC on Thursday said Comey
requested the meeting with trunk during
which Trump asked Comey if he wanted to
stay on as head of the FBI officials
have said to NBC no no James Comey
didn't request that meeting it was the
White House that requested that meeting
that's sort of a basic factual
misstatement of what the circumstances
of the meeting were and then a former
senior official also said that James
Comey whether or not Trump was under
investigation specifically James Comey
never would have specifically said to
the president you're not under
investigation also two people who heard
of the James Comey account of the
meeting told the New York Times that
Donald Trump allegedly asked James Comey
to pledge political loyalty to trump and
Comey reportedly said I promise honesty
but not loyalty which corroborates the
more general consensus about James Comey
and and again it goes back against the
characterization of Trump but although
no one believes that it's Comey who
might have recorded that meeting maybe
Trump did in any case if there are
recordings of that meeting senior House
Democrats have now demanded that Donald
Trump turned them over Congressman John
Conyers and Elijah Cummings the top
Democrats on the House Judiciary and
oversight committees wrote to white
House Counsel done the gun asking
whether such tapes exist and requesting
copies if they do congressman Adam
Schiff the top Democrat on the House
Intelligence Committee issued a
statement saying that Trump must either
provide tapes to Congress or admit that
he made them up and I read that and
thought admit he made them up Trump will
admit he made up the existence of these
tapes possible existence of these tapes
if it indeed is they don't exist as soon
as he admits that he made up the
assertion that three to five million
people voted illegally for Hillary
Clinton as soon as he makes up that
admits that he made up the claim that he
had record inauguration attendance as
soon as he admits that he made up the
claim that Obama wiretapped him and the
claim that he'll build a wall with
Mexico that Mexico will pay for and that
everyone will be covered under his
replacement to Obamacare I could go on
as soon as he admits that he made up all
those things maybe he would admit that
he made up the possible existence of
these tapes how wacky is this though
because it is yet another Nixon
connection last week after James Comey
was fired I said this is sort of
reminiscent of the Saturday Night Live
Saturday it's not Saturday Night Live
the Saturday night massacre involving
Richard Nixon and Archibald Cox in the
Watergate scandal we know how that ended
and here's yet another connection to
Watergate with the tapes in 1973
Alexander Butterfield was testifying
before Congress and answered some minor
questions sort of offhandedly about
checking the tapes the question
everybody had in response was wait a
second what tapes are you talking about
that's what started the revelation that
there were recordings in the Oval Office
that of course ultimately led to a
massive legal fight those tapes were
subpoenaed and ultimately led to Richard
Nixon's resignation things certainly
don't appear to be calming down anytime
soon as far as that investigation goes
send me your thoughts about this I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
Twitter at David Pakman show we'll take
a break and be back with much more right
after this
today's program is sponsored in part by
movement watch's movement watches has a
history similar to the David Pakman show
in that it was started by two broke
college kids that wanted stylish watches
they couldn't afford them they would go
to the big department stores and watch
as they liked were four or five hundred
dollars and they actually used
crowdfunding to launch their company
they decided to sell entirely online cut
out any of the middle people cut out the
retail markup and provide watches
starting at just $95 you see a couple of
the designs here
you're watching with us today I'm
wearing my movement watch which I love
people see it they say what is that
watch that's really cool I like that and
they've now sold over half a million
watches in over 160 countries you can
step up your watch game and get 15% off
plus free shipping and free returns by
going to mV mt watches dot-com / PA que
ma n okay that's 15% off free shipping
free returns MV mt watches calm / PA que
ma n